madame mademoiselle monsieur bonsoir
dans l'histoire de notre émission voici
ce soir un dossier qui mérite une
attention toute particulière parce que
nous allons évoquer une des plus grandes
tragédies de l'histoire contemporaine
je veux parler de ce qui se passe au
cambodge depuis bientôt cinq ans et
l'envoyer vous tandis que l'indochine
vivait pratiquement en état de guerre
depuis 1945 le cambodge avait réussi à y
échapper pendant une période que l'on
peut établir de 1953 1970 grosso modo et
que paradoxalement c'est quand la guerre
du vietnam s'est achevée et que les
vietnamiens ont fait leur entrée dans
saigon sur les talons des américains qui
ont requis ans partait que les malheurs
du peuple cambodgien ont commencé et
ceci se passait je vous le rappelle mais
vous l'avez pas oublier sûrement en
avril 1975
car alors que la paix s'établisse et au
vietnam au cambodge des khmers rouges
prenez le pouvoir et en moins de quatre
ans
ces hommes ont réussi à exterminer près
de la moitié de la population
cambodgienne 3,3 millions de personnes
comment est bien par la déportation les
mauvais traitements et l'assassinât pur
et simple
et depuis des mois seulement nous avons
découvert avec stupeur ce qui avait pu
se passer en mesurer toute l'étendue
grâce à des reportages que vous avez
vues sur antenne 2 qui nous ont montré
ces villes désertes
c'est inducta femme et ses enfants
squelettiques ces quatre millions de
survivants qui sont des fantômes et des
survivants pour combien de temps alors
ce que nous voulions faire ce soir avec
votre concours c'est essayer de dégager
deux points et si possible de suggérer
des solutions
première solution qu'est ce que nous
pouvons faire pour que les malheureux
survivants du cambodge puisse recouvrer
la santé
en dépit de tout ce qui est fait car il
ya beaucoup de choses qui sont faites on
en voit
vivre du ravitaillement des produits
médicaux mais est ce que ces produits
médicaux parviennent bien à leur
destinataire c'est une question que nous
traiterons et sinon pourquoi nous
essaierons d'examiner aussi si au fond
tout cela n'est pas une solution tout à
fait provisoire est illusoire dans la
mesure où seule une solution politique
pour est assurée au cambodge une
relative neutralité stabilité mais alors
cette solution politique
elle passe fatalement par les deux
grands puissance de l'asie c'est à dire
l'union soviétique qui soutient le
vietnam et la chine qui soutient au
moins provisoirement les khmers rouges
et qui peut imposer une solution et le
retrait des vietnamiens dans leur
territoire
c'est le deuxième foyer enfin il faudra
bien que quelqu'un nous dise et nous
avons ici des témoins qui peuvent
expliquer la chose qui sont les khmers
rouges pourquoi ils ont décidé ce
génocide et comment ils l'ont pratiqué
alors pour parler de tout cela nous
avons plusieurs personnes parfaitement
qualifiés et en premier lieu un témoin
qui nous vient de loin qui est
probablement celui qui connaît le mieux
le cambodge puisqu'il y est n'est qu'il
en a été le souverain je veux parler du
prince norodom sihanouk est à ma droite
et qui est monté sur le trône cambodgien
en 1941 il a exercé la royauté pendant
plusieurs années puis l'a dit qu'elle
est devenue chef du gouvernement et puis
pour peu de temps sur la fin président
de la république avant de partir pour
l'exil où il vit encore en chine ou en
corée du nord
le prince norodom sihanouk a écrit
récemment un ouvrage intitulé chroniques
de guerre et d'espoir où il compte
toutes les épreuves que son peuple a
traversé et lui avec son peuple dans les
années qui viennent de s'écouler
j'ai à ma gauche monsieur pini à tai chi
est un cambodgien
ingénieur civil qui raconte dans un
ouvrage intitulé utopie meurtrière qui
paraîtra au mois de janvier le martyre
du peuple cambodgien et monsieur piñata
il n'est pas n'importe quel témoin car
il a vécu pendant 26 mois
l'enfer des khmers rouges
je me contenterai de vous dire qu'il est
le seul rescapé d'une famille de 18
personnes
kylie a perdu sa femme ses enfants ses
parents ses frères et ses soeurs et pour
le cas où vous douteriez de la tragédie
qu'avec monsieur piñata je vais montrer
simplement une photo celle ci c'est lui
monsieur pigna taille tel qu'il était
quand il est arrivé en thaïlande après
26 mois de camp chez les khmers rouges
je n'en dis pas plus pour l'instant
troisième invité le docteur claude
malhuret qui est le secrétaire général
de médecins sans frontières et qui
depuis 1976 a eu maintes occasions de se
rendre dans les camps de réfugiés
cambodgiens en thaïlande puis le docteur
jean il faut le joug qui est le
président du comité français des deux
médical et sanitaire à la population
cambodgienne et qui lui aussi a fait de
fréquents séjours à proximité du
territoire cambodgien au cambodge même
le perp ou chaud qui est un prêtre qui a
vécu au cambodge de 1965 à 1975 qui est
l'auteur d'un ouvrage intitulé cambodge
année zéro et qui s'occupe activement de
la communauté cambodgienne en france
actuellement
monsieur alain madelin député d'ille et
vilaine était avec six autres députés
udf en mission au cambodge il ya
quelques jours il est rentré ce matin et
il nous racontera tout ce qu'il a vu et
entendu là-bas
jean lacouture écrivain est notamment
l'auteur d'un livre intitulé survivre
le peuple cambodgien william shawcross
journaliste anglais auteur d'une
tragédie sans importance où il est
établi et nous en parlerons tout à
l'heure que le malheur du peuple
cambodgien d'après monsieur shawcross a
à son origine
des erreurs et des fautes commises par
le président dixon et le docteur kiss in
her wilfred burchett journaliste autre
australien est un écrivain très connu et
en tout cas comme spécialiste de l'asie
du sud est
notre confrère paul nahon enfin
journaliste à antenne 2 où il s'occupe
depuis déjà plusieurs années de
politique étrangère ce qui lui a valu
d'aller à plusieurs reprises au vietnam
avant et après 1975 ainsi qu'au cambodge
où il était encore au mois de mai
dernier
je sais depuis déjà une demi heure
environ que vous êtes tellement nombreux
à essayer de vouloir rejoindre ce soir
que le standard de svp bloqué c'est
pourquoi je vais passer tout de suite la
parole a dit darwin nous vous écoutons
et bien ce soir joseph pasteur vous en
doutez après les images terribles qui
viennent de d'être diffusés l'émotion
est à son comble et avec anne-marie
l'amaury on peut souvent lire sur les
fiches ce cri sauver le peuple
cambodgien par tous les moyens
et puis cette question que faire je
serais d'accord dit à nos correspondants
si l'on voulait me confier un petit
cambodgien mais est il seulement
possible d'en adopter ou bien en dehors
de l'argent des vêtements comment
peut-on aider les cambodgiens est il
possible de recevoir des familles
certains ont déjà tenté et s'avoue déçu
quand on offre sa bonne volonté dit aux
professeurs quand on offre sa bonne
volonté au bord gagny semi officielle on
se voit répondre qu'on a qu'on n'a pas
besoin de vous c'est décevant
après l'émotion vient la colère on
dénonce des coupables est parmi les
premiers on nous dit les responsables en
france ce sont ceux qui depuis 1975
ignorant ce qui s'est passé là ignore ce
qui s'est passé là-bas la presse
française les intellectuels de gauche et
le gouvernement
certains vont plus loin vos invités ont
tous été à la base au début des amis des
khmers rouges
et lorsqu'ils disent toutes vos invités
il s'adresse beaucoup à jean lacouture
et surtout au prince yanouk monseigneur
vous ne serez pas étonné d'apprendre que
à côté des correspondants qui vous
assurent de leur compassion et de leurs
prières pour le malheureux cambodge
comme ils disent et qui vous assurent
également de leur soutien
il y à d'autres appels qui nous
parviennent et qui sont autant de
critiques à l'encontre de votre
politique et du comportement que vous
avez eue pendant les dernières années
qui viennent de s'écouler
nous y reviendrons
tout à l'heure je pense que les trois
grandes critiques qui que je retrouve
dans les fiches qui nous sont adressées
on peut les résumer de la façon suivante
certains téléspectateurs vous reproche
d'avoir été au début un ami des khmers
rouges
ils vous reprochent d'être resté pendant
très longtemps dans l'ignorance du
génocide qui s'est déroulé et
troisièmement ils vous reprochent votre
exil a auprès des chinois mais vous
répondrai à ces questions tout à l'heure
parce que pour l'instant ce qui
intéresse mais vraiment tout le monde
c'est de savoir ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui
que savons-nous exactement de ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui au cambodge
comment peut-on répondre à cette
question aussi vaste mais aussi clair
que cela mon seigneur voulait répondre
en quelques mots ou d'après les
renseignements que vous avez et puis
nous interrogerons nous autres invités
qu'est ce qui se passe aujourd'hui au
cambodge est ce que vous savez j'ai reçu
des renseignements sur la situation du
cambodge
la situation actuelle de plusieurs
compatriotes qui ont pu quitter l'enfer
cambodgien tout récemment qu'ils se
trouvent soit entre landes soit en
france même
cela me disent que les biens amiens
malgré que il possède une armée très
puissante contrôle très mal le cambodge
il y a des nids de résistance un peu
partout au cambodge des nationalistes
des khmers rouges se trouvent surtout
dans les zones qui touche
qui sont proches de la thaïlande
les montagnes cardamome nomma l'ail et
ses draps et aussi au nord-est de ses
meilleurs amis
et puis dans les hauts plateaux près de
la frontière cambodgienne a mais
cambodge laos ratanakiri mondulkiri il y
a des poches des nids de résistance
donc en résumé environ trois cinquièmes
du cambodge sont plus ou moins bien
contrôlé par les vietnamiens
il y à un cinquième de mon pays qui
n'est pas contrôlée par les vietnamiens
n'est pas contrôlée non plus parler les
résistants anti viande en bien et puis
le cinquième qui reste alors est aux
mains des khmers rouges d'une part et
des khmers nationaliste d'autre part
bien je vous remercie
je crois qu'il faut essayer de préciser
un peu calé quelle est la situation
alors au plan de la population alors je
vais interroger monsieur madelin pour
une simple raison c'est que je vous ai
dit tout à l'heure monsieur bah delà est
rentré ce matin même du cambodge dites
nous ce que vous avez vous vous êtes
allé d'abord pendant combien de temps ce
que vous avez vu et entendu et je suis
rentré ce matin avec une délégation de
députés udf sept autres députés udf
nous avons été aux api open
pendant un peu plus de trois jours et
nous rentrons spa avec bouleversé avec
sans doute la même émotion courivaud
téléspectateurs tout à l'heure en
regardant ces images atroces
nous avons pu je crois échappé à la
vigilance de nos guides qui nous avait
préparé une visite bien organisé une
montre en ce qu'ils avaient envie de
nous montrer et nous avons pu recueillir
à phnom penh dans la banlieue de phnom
penh et puis ensuite dans les camps
thaïlandais mais je parle surtout à
phnom penh même nous avons pu recueillir
un certain nombre de témoignages vos
guides jeu made là c'était des
vietnamiens ont des noms nous étions
garder dans la maison qu'ils avaient été
mis à notre disposition nous étions
gardée par des vietnamiens mais nous
étions accompagnés par des cambodgiens
nous avons quand même pu malgré cela un
peu leur fils et compagnie et réunir des
témoignages en nous promenant dans les
rues de phnom penh à leur insu en
rencontrant des gens et je crois que
nous revenons avec le sentiment
qu'aujourd'hui le cambodge
eh bien ces images que vous avez vu ce
n'est pas du tout terminé cela continue
a qu'un génocide qui correspondait à la
période de 75 depuis 79 un lien d'autres
génocides qui est à l'heure actuelle en
cours et que le cambodge aujourd'hui
c'est le cambodge je dirais de la peur
et de la fin des anecdotes nous en avons
de nombreuses gélade et des lettres qui
m'ont été remis dans les rues de phnom
penh par des cambodgiens général en jeu
dans la lettre d'un enfant de la part
d'un homme fort cela qui se termine par
sauf sauvez moi je vous en supplie je la
lettre d'un cambodgiens qui me dit les
territoires occupés par les vietnamiens
le peuple souffre encore malgré l'aide
internationale le peuple aux khmers
continuent de mourir des vietnamiens ont
pillé le riz et les semences
nous n'avons pas le droit de cultiver
notre terre le riz mûri nous n'avons pas
le droit de le moissonné les vietnamiens
le gardent pour eux pour nous envoyer au
vietnam
une partie de l'aide internationale est
prise par les vietnamiens affirme-t-il
les assassins sont maintenant les
vietnamiens cette présence vietnamienne
nous l'avons ressenti c'est à dire qu'au
pouvoir cambodgien qui est à l'heure
actuelle en place le pouvoir de monsieur
sam ring il y à un autre pouvoir que
nous n'avons pas vu mais que nous
sentons bien et que dans les rues de
phnom penh chaque fois que nous voulons
nous entretenir avec quelqu'un nous
sentons bien c'est la crainte
une anecdote une seule lorsque nous
rencontrons des cambodgiens qui parlent
français et ceci nous disent eh bien
nous avons de la famille en france
nous avons eu une mère nous avons un
frère voici mon nom new delhi sur un
morceau de papier
dites-leur en france que nous sommes
vivants mais surtout qu'ils nous
envoient plus jamais de l'être car dans
le cambodge aujourd'hui envoyé une
lettre c'est condamner quelqu'un dhr
alors il ya une chose que les
téléspectateurs aimeraient certainement
savoir
il y a gelé dit tout à l'heure en
présentant cette émission un grand
effort de solidarité qui ce qui se situe
à l'échelle internationale en faveur des
malheureux cambodgien est ce que le
ravitaillement les médicaments le
parviennent à leurs destinataires ou
bien ce qu'ils sont détournés je
voudrais pas prendre trop longuement la
parole mais là aussi nous avons un
certain nombre d'éléments réunis par mes
camarades du leff et moi même d'abord
l'aide
elle arrive elle est stockée elle est
stockée et ensuite aller distribuer je
dirais un peu au compte-gouttes je
m'explique
reste que nous avons interrogé le
président samrin nous avons interrogé le
ministère étrangères pour leur demander
d'après vous quelle est l'aide
internationale que vous avez reçu sept
nuls total ceux ci nous ont fait un
total en nous disant voilà nous avons
reçu jusqu'à présent 4039 tonnes par dix
mais c'est pas possible 4039 tonnes rien
que dans le port dock au programme
depuis un peu moins d'un mois il ya
vingt-deux mille six cents tonnes qui
sont arrivés alors qu'est ce qui se
passe rien que le bateau l'île de
lumière qui est arrivé à phnom penh
s'étaient 12 cents tonnes et nous dit
bah oui bah on s'est peut-être nous on
n'a peut-être pas tous comptabilisés
l'aide en réalité à les stocker elle est
stockée à phnom penh
elle est stockée également accompli
somme qu'est ce qu'elle devient c'était
d'esquel paris aux populations je crois
que c'est la grande question que l'on se
pose oui ils doivent se poser les
téléspectateurs là dessus si vous
interrogez les gens dans les villes
autonomes peine ceci vous dise l'aide ne
parvient pas à la population votre aide
internationale où est l on la voit pas
il vous affirme aussi bien volontiers
que cette aide est volé par les
vietnamiens
cela étant sûr nous n'avons pas de
preuve que s'étaient détournés pour
notre part nous avons recueilli aucun
élément nous permettant d'affirmer que
cette aide va au vietnam je peux vous
apporter par contre un témoignage c'est
que nous avons rencontré une colonne de
camions vietnamien qui étaient réunis
devant l'ambassade de france était très
ancienne ambassade de france dans une
région se trouvent les entrepôts dans
lequel sont stockées cette aide nous
avons demandé à les voir on n'a pas
voulu parce que nous avons pris la route
numéro 5 7 qui mène vers la région où l
heure actuelle les vietnamiens il essaie
de s'implanter
on a réussi à retrouver cette colonne on
a interrogé alain les chauffeurs de car
et on a fini par tomber sur un chauffeur
qui parlait français on lui a demandé
mais c'était tout va t'elle nous a dit
dans quelle ville elle allait à qui est
elle destinée aux cambodgiens ou
vietnamiens vous a répondu elle est
destinée aux vietnamiens
donc là je vous rapporte un témoignage
personnel montrant qu'il ya certainement
une partie de cet aigle qui est destiné
aux vietnamiens
pour le reste nous ne savons pas ce
qu'elle devient le paria population si
ce n'est que les vietnamiens contrôle
étroitement le robinet du riz nous avons
eu le sentiment qu'il commence un tout
petit peu à le distribuer dans un
certain nombre de régions
c'est à dire que il distribuer cette
aide au fur et à mesure qu'il mettre en
place leur contrôle politique dans
chaque prenant phnom penh pour n'importe
quel village
vous avez un comité qui se met en place
un comité qui est composé d'un délégués
élus par la population soit disant
désignés par la population mais des
membres du parti d'un autre délégué qui
est désigné par le parti par le district
est désigné par le parti d'un soldat
cambodgien d'art d'un soldat cambodgien
et surtout d'un soldat vietnamien
c'était cette structure de quatre
personnes qui décident qui encadrent
politiquement à quartier et qui décide
de l'attribution du riz alors au fur et
à mesure que ceux-ci soient mis en place
nous avons assisté à une distribution
est bien que sur les listes si les gens
sont bien dociles ou nouveau pouvoir
eh bien on ouvre un tout petit peu le
robinet et on leur donne un peu un peu
grillé en fonction de leur docilité
voilà je crois qu'il est telle qu'elle
se met en place aujourd'hui alors est ce
qu'il ya de la part des médecins ici
présents du père ponchaud qui a
certainement pas mal d'informations des
observations complémentaires docteur
foals ou a présenté sur la distri
juan de l'aide oui j'ai eu le privilège
d'aller au cambodge au mois de mai pour
la première fois émettant du compte de
la situation sanitaire dans ce pays
médical est aussi un problème
alimentaire
j'ai décidé avec un semble de mes
collègues médecins à une époque où
l'aide internationale des pays
occidentaux n'existait pas au mois de
mai savait qu'elle est toute récente
d'essayer en france de faire quelque
chose pour aider la population
cambodgienne et pour aider à améliorer
cette condition sanitaire et médicale
nous avons créé ce comité et nous avons
essayé de réunir les efforts de
nombreuses organisations humanitaires
françaises
le comité catholique contre la faim
le secours populaire français la cimade
le secours catholique
de nombreuses organisations ce qui nous
a permis au mois d'août d'arriver les
premiers français d'une part et les
premiers occidentaux également à phnom
penh avec un avion de 40 tonnes de
médicaments et de matériel médical et ce
qui nous a permis les forces
développement et la sensibilisation la
suite de cette campagne devenant plus
importante en france 2 d'être en train
actuellement de réaliser une opération
qui va nous permettre d'apporter de
faire parvenir trois avions de matériel
médical de lait en poudre et 2
médicaments au cambodge alors intervenir
sur l'inde et votre intervention
monsieur madeleine jeudi on me sidère
est la vôtre aussi
c'est à dire les médecins qui vous
représente ce cas je crois qu'elle sait
rien est de le dire pour le
téléspectateur sont des militants
communistes donc mais c'est surtout des
gens pas d'aimer débilitant comme lisa
attendez laissez les séjours d'amis à
voir les roues critiquerait à précision
pas des militants communistes ce sont
des médecins qui ont décidé de prendre
sur leur temps pour aider la population
cambodgienne
et quand bien même serait-il communiste
serait-il de toute autre tendance
philosophique permettez moi de dire que
le fait qu'il y ait des médecins qui a
aidé les médecins français ou plus qui a
aidé la population cambodgienne
je m'en réjouis et je dis votre
témoignage me sidère car il y a entre
vous et moi quelqu'un ici qui ne dit pas
la vérité car votre témoignage j'ai été
deux fois au cambodge au mois de mai au
mois d'août il y a encore des personnes
qui sont au cambodge appartenant à
toutes les organisations auxquelles je
viens de faire allusion et aucune de ces
personnes ne témoignent des choses que
vous venez de lire pour l'aide
internationale
c'est vrai qu'il ya des difficultés
premièrement il faut reconnaître que
cette aide a été tardive c'est au mois
et à la suite de cette première
opération 7 au mois de septembre
seulement que les pays occidentaux
faut dire quand même ont décidé de faire
cette campagne d' aide humanitaire pour
votre pays
monseigneur lui deuxièmement il est
exact que sur place existe des
difficultés considérables pour
l'utilisation actuellement de cette aide
et ses difficultés
elles sont la conséquence bien
évidemment de l'état dans lequel pendant
quatre ans a été mis ce pays ce pays qui
a été absolument anéanti dans tout ce
qui est la structure sociale
la structure l'infrastructure économique
les routes les hôpitaux l'école la
monnaie il ne reste plus rien il ne
restait qu'une population de quatre peut
être cinq millions espérons de
cambodgiens affaibli malnutries et
traumatique
sheep man c'était ça la situation du
cambodge quand j étais au mois de mai et
qu'il venait d'être libéré et il est
bien évidemment il est bien évident que
ces conditions humaines et matérielles
font qu'il est très difficile
immédiatement de pouvoir assurer la
répartition de ses peines
mais il y a un troisième homme seul a
dit l'aide arrive et nous avons pu nous
mêmes accompagnés dans des régions comme
qu'on peut jusqu'à jusqu'à encore
jusqu'à ce qu'ils aimeraient des parties
de l'aide alimentaire et médicale
et quand nous faisons actuellement des
plans et nous sommes en train de faire
avec des organisations internationales
humanitaires catholiques communistes
protestant de toutes origines car ce qui
compte ce n'est pas la nature de ces
organisations ce qui compte c'est ce
qu'ils font pour sauver ce peuple
actuellement c'est ça important il y à
un troisième obstacle c'est
effectivement la difficulté qu'il y a à
franchir certains barrages au niveau
international et je vais vous prendre un
exemple très simple
notre opération parfaitement planifié de
trois avions devaient être terminés pour
le 15 novembre nous sommes aujourd'hui
le 27 novembre
deux avions seulement son parti pour le
cambodge et le premier avion a été
retardé de quinze jours permettez moi de
vous dire pourquoi parce que nous avons
nous n'avons pu obtenir l'autorisation
des autorités thaïlandaises et
malaisienne de survoler leur territoire
pour apporter cette aide d'urgence
permettez moi de vous dire également que
d'après les déclarations de la
croix-rouge et nous collaborons sur
place monsieur madeleine avec les
représentants de la croix-rouge et de
l'unicef et tous les témoignages que
nous avons pu faire concorde
parfaitement avec ce témoignage
l'onu a débloqué un crédit de 135
millions de dollars pour l'aide
humanitaire
il ya maintenant bientôt un mois
actuellement 12 millions de dollars
seulement ont été débloqués pour cette
aide humanitaire qui est l'essentiel de
cette aide se trouve en thaïlande pour
vous dire qu'effectivement il existe des
difficultés des difficultés internes
dues à l'état d' d'affaiblissement est à
l'état de ruines dans lequel mais rouges
ont laissé ce pays mais aussi des
difficultés qui sont de la
responsabilité des puissances qui
organise cette aide donc une simple
question à laquelle vous êtes gentils de
répondre brièvement monsieur madelin a
laissé entendre dans son intervention
les vietnamiens qui occupent les trois
cinquièmes du pays le prince norodom m'a
dit toi tu leur contrôle l'est ou
contrôle peut être la détourne parfois
il n'a pas de façon formelle mais c'est
ce qu'on a plus qu'on prend est ce que
tu es gens firme ait ou pas je ne
confirme pas jeudi nous sommes en france
actuellement
moi je ne fais pas je refuse de faire de
politique quelles que soient mes
opinions politiques
et j'ai le droit dans la voie en étant
citoyen je ne veux pas dans cette
émission faire de politique je veux
témoigner absolue je veux simplement
témoigner sur ce que j'ai vu est ce que
j'ai vu au cambodge ce que j'ai entendu
de centaines de témoignages j'ai passé
plus d'un mois en tout cette année
jantes j'ai pu entendre des peut-être un
millier de témoignages j'aurais vous
faire remarquer d'abord que cette armée
iata mienne si redoutable si vous avez
pu tromper sa vigilance pour aller vous
promener dans phnom penh c'est quand
même que la guerre n'est pas très sévère
cela dit ce que j'ai vu est ce que j'ai
entendu dans phnom penh dans les
différentes régions du cambodge car j'ai
aussi beaucoup voyagé au cambodge c'est
premièrement incontestablement de la
part des cambodgiens la reconnaissance
du fait que les vietnamiens les ont
libérés d'une des camps de concentration
comme été les conséquences anciens nazis
comme étaient les camps de concentration
nazis et croyez moi cette vieille reine
on veut nous inculquer entre les
cambodgiens et les vietnamiens si vous
me permettez l'expression elle en a pris
un coup
elle en a pris un coup parce que les
clés mer en seigneur reconnaissent que
les vietnamiens les ont libérés de la
quelles que soient les motivations de la
plus d'une des plus atroces histoire
d'une des plus atroces tragédie de
l'humanité la deuxième chose que je
tiens à dire également au niveau du
contrôle de l'aide humanitaire c'est que
jusqu'au mois d'août les vietnamiens et
les pays qui avaient reconnu le régime
actuel il est ce qu'il est ce n'est pas
mon problème était les seuls je dis bien
médias tammy à ces pays à apporter une
aide humanitaire au cambodge et ses
camions
vous avez vu devant l'ambassade de
france à phnom penh hun sur la droite a
juste après l'hôtel aux étiez cas
probablement vous étiez l'hôtel samaki
ou très peu ces camions il était là au
mois de mai il était là au mois d'août
ce sont des camions effectivement qui
apporte du riz du vietnam
ils sont là pourquoi sur cette place à
côté de l'ambassade de france parce que
le garage des camions vietnamien
est situé dans l'ambassade de france
nous avons d'ailleurs publié des photos
de nous même envoyer ses photos à des
représentants diplomatiques
c'est le garage des camions verte amiens
qui apporte le riz au vietnam abordé
monsieur madelin j'ai invoqué un
troisième témoin y un docteur malhuret
qu'est ce que vous dites de tout ça je
crois qu'on est actuellement sidérait de
part et d'autre et moi je dois dire que
je suis également si dirais comme vous
dites dr fall où il y a quelqu'un qui ne
dit pas la vérité
et moi j'ai l'impression que en tout cas
mon témoignage et les témoignages que
j'ai recueillis ils vont dans le sens de
ce que dit monsieur madelin je le
regrette
et pourquoi n'y avons pas avec nous
pourquoi dd non pas avec vous mais
personnellement pas les visas pour aller
au camp cette idée parce que depuis un
an parce que vous dites que depuis que
jusqu'au mois d'août il n'y a pas eu des
internationales au cambodge
mais depuis un an médecins sans
frontières depuis dix mois et vit avec
la nièce ont pénétré au cambodge
médecins sans frontières essaye d'y
pénétrer et celle d'avoir les visas
envoûtant on nous a accordé les visas
pendant cinq jours où une visite guidée
que nous avons fait avec vous notre
médecin a repris l'avion et depuis nous
ne pouvons plus travailler
nous avons 70 médecins actuellement en
thaïlande qui essaye de sauver les
quelques cadavres qu'on veut à qui on
veut bien laisser passer la frontière du
côté de ça ne m'était pas de condition
physique à votre intervention au cul
qu'on ne peut être comme nous nous était
pas de compter sur collins et conditions
politiques méritons des conditions
techniques nous sommes une organisation
de médecins vous avez déclarez vous
vraiment mois de mai en rentrant de
votre premier voyage là-bas qu' il n'y
avait plus que 40 médecins sur les 500
du cambodge qu'il n'y avait plus
d'hôpitaux je n'avais plus le matériel
je suis intervenu dans votre conférence
de presse pour vous proposer l'aide non
pas au bout de quelques mois pour vous
proposer l'aide immédiate parce que vous
savez que médecins sans frontières est
spécialisée dans l'intervention urgente
en cas de catastrophe pour vous proposer
la lime avec les élus à coude de
journalistes de nos médecins de nos
hôpitaux de notre matériel qui ont d
envoyer immédiatement pour sauver les
boat people vietnamiens qui ont été
envoyées immédiatement pour sauver les
gens a sacrément fait dans les trois
jours ce n'était pas dans les six mois
vous nous n'avons jamais obtenu
autre chose qu'un visa pour un médecin
pour cinq jours au vietnam
actuellement en médecins sans frontières
au cambodge perdre à curan mais ça s'en
vient on ne travaille pas au cambodge
le cicr et l'unicef qui sont les
associations qui existent depuis
longtemps le cicr c'est le comité
international de la croix rouge l'unicef
représente l'onu ont actuellement alors
qu'ils avaient demandé lien
mois d'août d'entrée au cambodge on est
actuellement quatre personnes pour les 1
6 personnes pour les autres qui sont
bloqués à phnom penh et qui font
national la visite guidée phnom penh
comprendre un peu ce que nous avons fait
et c'est que tout le monde fait
actuellement gelée pasteur voudrais
terminer là dessus nous sommes
vous parliez tout à l'heure des camps de
concentration nazis nous sommes en place
du 3e génocide du xxème siècle il faut
que tout le monde le sache et d'ailleurs
tout le monde s'en est aperçu du temps
des arméniens du génocide arménien
j'étais tanné c'était quelque chose qui
se passait loin et la plupart des gens
ne voudraient pas parler du temps du
génocide des juifs
beaucoup de gens dont on ait parlé mais
les voies ont été camouflés je dis
qu'actuellement le génocide au cambodge
qui a été commencé par les khmers rouges
et là tu nous sommes tous d'accord que
le génocide se poursuit et je trouve que
quand vous parlez des camps d'auschwitz
le témoignage que vous rapportez sur le
cambodge me fait penser à ces gens des
commissions internationales qui au
moment de la guerre allait auschwitz et
à qui on sortait un juif pour jouer du
violon et il disait tout se passe bien
aux 8 il n'y a pas de compte en
attendions il n'a pas de gens qui sont
gazés c'est exactement ce que vous êtes
en train de dire actuellement au vietnam
je suis désolé de parler aussi
violemment
mais je ne veux pas supporté
qu'actuellement on dit ce que tout se
passe bien on attendait comme le
gouvernement vietnamien que l'avenir est
radieux parce que c'est l'été on de
lagence de presse cambodgienne
actuellement à l'honneur pour jour des
failles des repas pour moi je voudrais
de par mon travail d'ailleurs je suis en
relation au travail qu'un travail
d'information et d'études aussi
sociologique sur les religions en france
je suis en rapport avec des cambodgiens
à l'intérieur du cambodge
ce n'est pas ce que vous avez vu et je
pense que mes sources sont valables
puisqu'elle m'ont permis de décrire la
société khmère rouge en 76 ans 77 déjà
même des jambes afin 75 jean lacouture
en est témoin enfin 75 ces mêmes sources
pouvait déjà me permettre d'affirmer un
certain nombre de choses sur le régime
démentiel de polpot et en 77 les
français qui voulaient connaître la
vérité le pouvait ces mêmes sources
actuelles me permettent également
actuellement d'affirmer avec la même
autorité que nous sommes en face d'un
génocide
après le génocide sanguinaire de polpot
qui a coûté la vie de 2,3 millions
d'habitants je pense au moins deux tiers
de la population
nous sommes après la libération du
cambodge par le vietnam ou l'invasion du
cambodge par là mais vietnamienne selon
le bord idéologique auquel nous
appartenons à un troisième génocide plus
subtile par exemple j'ai un petit
exemple j'ai reçu une lettre datée du 27
octobre qui parvient du sud de
battambang dessus de la pagode de watts
corps qui me dit si dans quinze jours
les aides internationales ne vienne pas
nous serons tous morts
c'est un international d'après les
renseignements que j'ai essayé de
rassembler elle arrive à phnom penh
effectivement et je crois ce que vous
avez dit est en partie exact que vous
avez dit vous monsieur madelin est en
fait exact si je crois pour aux deux
tests ne sont pas totalement
contradictoire je pense que dans la
région de phnom penh il y a une certaine
distribution de l'aide c'est exact dans
la région de battambang je puis vous
donner un nombre un très très grand
nombre d'exemples par exemple 16 octobre
il y à 45 camions qui sont arrivés à
battambang pas d'attendre exactement à
montcoal borreil il ya quatre camions
qui ont été vendus à raison de 26 est
une mesure le nord pour vanina qui vont
à qui mon père venduoo à ceux qui
pouvaient payer aux khmers qui pouvaient
payer et le pauvre peuple est mort de
faim et ce alors les témoignages
abondent dans ce sens là
d'autre part les vietnamiens
actuellement profitent de cette aide
pourrait changer un sac de riz contre un
boeuf un boeuf veau est encore un buzz
qui est jeune bien portant et gras si le
boeuf est vieux
un maigre ce sera un demi sac les
vietnamiens également échange le riz
contre des chiens c'est par exemple 250
boîte pour un chien bien pourtant etc
je trouvais beau ce qu'il mange le chien
volt et les vietnamiens comme ange déchu
c'est d'ailleurs une dans les
caractéristiques les cambodgiens disait
la mer les mangeurs de chiens donc cette
aide internationale
dire qu'elle n'arrive pas me paraît
exagéré dire que la rive en totalité me
paraît exagéré et fo je pense qu'une
toute petite partie arrive effectivement
aux cambodgiens et aux riches et dans
tous les cas et utiliser que moyen de
pression pour attirer la population
alors je ne veux pas me placer comme
vous monsieur fall ou sur un plan
politique mais reconnaissons que l'aide
humanitaire ne peut absolument pas se
dégager du plan politique je fais pas de
politique
non non mais moi je refuse de faire de
la politique humanitaire
son épouse avait dit si vous avez dit
quelque chose de très important
vous avez dit que au génocide commis par
les khmers rouges et polpot a suivi un
génocide beaucoup plus subtil voulez
vous précisez votre subtil est planifié
je dirais même plus voyez par exemple
les vietnamiens sont ancrés à phnom penh
le 7 janvier 79 il ya à peu près dix
mois ensuite ils ont pris toutes les
routes nationales des grandes villes et
dans quelques temps après se sont
adonnés à un pillage systématique de
tout ce qui pouvait se trouver au 15 rue
et cela je puis l'affirmer avec la même
autorité que j'ai affirmé les massacres
des khmers rouges
ce n'est pas peu dire les vietnamiens au
masseur piller systématiquement tout ce
qu'ils trouvaient au cambodge à
commencer par les moteurs les voitures
laurie choses beaucoup plus graves
le riz qui a et c qui étaient stockés en
entrepôt coopératif ensuite au mois de
mai alors là mes sources également
abonde disent que les vietnamiens ont
interdit à la population khmère d'aller
cultiver les rizières éloigné des
villages dont on ne peut pas vivre est
actuellement l'homme et témoignages que
j'ai lu que j'ai reçu cette semaine pas
plus tard qu'hier je n'ai ensuite toute
une série me confirme ou confirment des
renseignements épars que j'avais
auparavant disant qu actuellement les
vietnamiens interdisent de faire la
moisson dans certains endroits comme à
saint brieuc ils ont ramassé les
fossiles dans d'autres endroits à
l'aigle et les soldats
on a mis en garde les rizières dans
d'autres arts droit ils ont miné les
alentours des rizières alors donner une
aide
je veux bien sauvé peuple khmer mais il
faut tout mettre en oeuvre pour sauver
le khmer le peuple khmer
mais après le génocide la compromission
ou d'autres délits collectif d'homicide
par non-assistance à personne en danger
qui a duré pendant quatre ans je
voudrais pas être compromis dans un
homicide par compromission avec des
assassins et c'est là le tout pour moi
la grosse question livre interrogations
nous nous allons revenir mon père quand
nous parlerons de la nécessité d'une
solution politique à la situation
8 frais de marché oui alors j'ai visité
deux fois cette année le combo du mois
de mai mois d'août mardi mais j'ai pris
la route de chi minh-ville cinq ans à
problèmes je rentre dans mon village
j'ai parlé j'aurais dû le moment quand
il avait toujours le mouvement mais j'en
rends très étonné de leur village
alors j'ai demandé cette question qui
ont beaucoup à faire avec la nature et
les portes en bois à faire la nature de
l'être il faut parce que nous je crois
que tous les chiffres cités sont
d'accord qu'à peu près au moins 40% de
la population était ou bien exterminer
au
modou fall mais quand on va dans une
village le niveau du village niveau de
district ou bien de province et on
demande combien d'hommes et là combien
des adultes de mâles
il ya à peu près de moyens ces quatre 4
femmes cinq femmes pour chaque lot ça
pose un problème terrible pour les
travaux et 3 mai cameron est humainement
j'ai visité six provinces ont tous les
moyens non c'était comme ça tu le payes
80% des légendes où tu mens tu es aimé
quand dans le rif la question des
techniciens et des techniciens de
réunion des maires de st c'est peut-être
90% et 95%
il n'y a plus de tout un cadre technique
cambodgiens qui tirait alors type aig
qui le parlent des routes qui conduirait
les camions réparer les chemins de verre
de sirop points
on peine actuellement c'est des
vietnamiens il ya beaucoup de bien aux
bas beaucoup de vietnamiens mais ils
sont apparaît ainsi donner ensuite un
méchant alors en ce qui concerne ribéry
tout ce que je sais des convois du rire
devient tenant nos longues cette re
entre l'ancien bavette 20 provinces de
thanh eu jusqu'à jusqu'à problèmes dans
certaines cages et vous les camions sont
dans les pays on a laissé de ripon je
suppose les
de l'administration le cadre de district
ou même vivement en ce qui concerne des
lettres je vous assure que vous n'aurez
pas raison j'ai amené pas mal de m il
faut dire que j'ai avec nous aucun doute
pendant cinq ans mes enfants sont allés
à l'école dosnon poison lycée des 4 j'ai
transmis beaucoup peuvent être mois de
mai transmet beaucoup de réponses mois
d'août et j'ai pu faciliter le départ
certains camarades de classe par exemple
de légende et amis de mes enfants je
n'ai jamais entendu le cas en tout cas
de mètres cubes maggi transportait qu'il
y avait une histoire
donc ça vous n'êtes pas d'accord avec ce
qu'a dit monsieur manuel et le père
ponchaud c'est bien ça jean lacouture
il me semble que la plupart des fêtes
qui ont été relégués ici sont justes
n'est pas la question des lettres
mettons là mettant la part n'est pas je
crois qu'effectivement ce qu'a dit
madelin malhuret follezou de son côté
tout cela et les observations sont
probablement sur est faite par des gens
honnêtes qui ont vu les choses
personnellement je ne suis pas depuis
très longtemps
malheureusement pour moi au cambodge ce
que je mettrais un peu en doutent
cela je voudrais qu'on pose la question
de savoir s'il ya pu y avoir vraiment un
actuellement une volonté systématique de
génocide organisé de la part des
vietnamiens d'extermination parce que si
c'était l'été la stratégie des
vietnamiens il n'avait qu'à laisser agir
avec mes rouge dire qu'ils n'avaient
qu'à laisser deux trois quatre ans de
plus le cambodge sous l'autorité de
potes et il restait plus de temps au
djihad je crois qu'ils allaient tous
ceux qui ont connu le cambodge au cours
des dernières années peuvent en
témoigner
il me semble un peu étrange que les
vietnamiens est saoul et courus non pas
du tout pour les régions une manière je
ne crois pas du tout que ce soit des
raisons humanitaires elle était
proprement stratégique et politique mais
il était très facile d'attendre que il
ne veut plus de cambodgiens que le vide
soit fait par paule botte et d'autre
part si leur objectif est un objectif de
caractère colonial ce que je crains ce
n'est pas une colonisation s'est fondé
sur une force de travail on a la queue
le dire
en france à l'aise au cambodge étaient
fondées sur une force de travail
cambodgienne est d'ailleurs aussi
partiellement vietnamienne je le fais tu
de dépeupler systématiquement le
cambodge me paraît extrêmement
irrationnel or on peut faire beaucoup de
reproches aux vietnamiens et j'en fais
personnellement beaucoup mais
l'irrationalité n'est pas exactement
leur fait alors je crois simplement
qu'on peut poser cette question de là
d'une volonté d'une stratégie
d'extermination et de génocides de la
part des vietnam l'irak
excusez moi est ce que les vietnamiens
ne pourrait pas tout simplement envisagé
de faire du cambodge une colonie de
peuplement simplement sur le lit ils ont
suffisamment dont il pas chez eux
franchement je passe le jointage une
question que je ne crois pas que ce soit
que ce soit pensable je ne crois pas que
ce soit économiquement rentable crois
pas que ce soit cela qu'on peut imaginer
je crois que on a besoin dans une
colonie une colonie encore une fois
d'avoir la base de force de travail
total alors monsieur madeleine courte
intervention puis nous retournons svp
pour savoir si les téléspectateurs nous
suivait et ce qu'ils voudraient savoir
plus je vous ai rapporté on vous a
rapporté des témoignages disant que les
vietnamiens par exemple interdisait les
récoltes que les vietnamiens minet les
rizières de façon à contrôler les
récoltes les vietnamiens vol totalement
contrôler l'alimentation des cambodgiens
avec l'arrière-pensée d'établir à le
contrôle politique
les vietnamiens veulent aussi sans doute
un certain nombre de régions qu'ils ne
contrôlent pas une femme de la fameuse
poche où il ya cinq cent mille personnes
veulent sans doute ne pas distribuer
l'aide alimentaire pour l'instant afin
d' affamer cette population soit pour
l'exterminer soit tout simplement
peut-être pour la rejeter vers
l'extérieur vers la thaïlande
mais il y a un point important ce que je
voudrais souligner c'est que dans ces
témoignages pour l'instant nous avons
été nous l'exception nous délégations et
des genoux l'exception la plupart du
temps le pouvoir en place ne concerne
n'admet sur place que des communistes
ce sont les médecins communiste dont on
parlait tout à l'heure et par exemple il
ya les médecins et médecins sans
frontières qui sont prêts à venir sans
doute en nombre très important cela on
leur interdit la prochaine arrivée de
médecins au vietnam au cambodge selon un
des médecins soviétique une hôtelière
sur place que des communistes soient des
compagnons de route c'est à dire des
gens qui ont fait la preuve de leur
docilité dans les témoignages permettez
moi de rappeler aux téléspectateurs
qu'en 1975 lorsque le régime de pol pot
to doc et aux 137 installé lorsqu'il ya
eu les premières exactions des khmers
rouges
lorsque l'on a vidé phnom penh de sa
population avec le cortège d'atrocités
qu'il y avait en même temps et bien dans
le même temps la presse française ou du
moins une certaine presse française
en tout pas pour l'humanité publié des
titres je les ai l'apnée peine libéré la
paix revenue des dizaines de milliers de
réfugiés regardent leurs villages
week-end de fête à cambodge indépendant
pacifique et prospère et cetera et
cetera il ya des témoins qui ne veulent
pas voir
et c'était moi nous en avons sur le
plateau monsieur burchett par exemple
monsieur burchett pardonnez moi de vous
le dire mais en toute amitié monsieur
burchett chirurgie est vous avez faisiez
partie comme journaliste australien de
ces témoins qui pendant la pire période
de la répression stalinienne en hongrie
notamment ne voulait pas voir monsieur
burchett vous avez eu à vous avez voyagé
son passeport vietnamiens vous allez
valait peut-être son passeport chinois
et son passeport cubain permettez moi de
penser que vous faites partie de ces
journalistes de ces témoin que l'on
promène dans des circuits organisés et
qu'ils ne veulent pas voir qu'ils ne
verront pas nous avons eu la chance
peut-être sur place d'avoir la volonté
notre incorrigible habitude de la
liberté d'échapper à cela de recueillir
des témoignages
croyez moi ces témoignages la sont
exactes et je suis certains hélas que
l'histoire validera ces témoignages
monsieur perchette désirez vous vous
défendre je suis comme une duperie très
longue date comme une amie du peuple
cambodgien je crois que monseigneur bien
affirmer que soutenir les chinois aussi
chinois est maintenant bien et
cambodgiens laotiens ensuite je connais
bien j'ai 25 ans dans ce coin
je crois que ce que ses bases et votre
été malin c'est terrible il n'a pas de
crédit qu'il n'y a pas de témoins tous
vous dites que vous avez parlé avec
aucun dans un coin de mon père
qu'est ce que ça vaut quand même un
sérieux de recherche un mot au sol jean
colinet séverine ont pas de querelles
personnelles non un témoignage
les vietnamiens à l'heure actuelle
continue l'extermination des
intellectuels si cette extermination
je vous aurais seconde l'extermination
des intellectuels 90% des intellectuels
ont été éliminés par régime clair
il en reste les vietnamiens continue au
mois de juin 79 juin 79
il ya quelques mois entre 300 et 400
intellectuels ont été arrêtés et si mes
renseignements sont exacts 328
intellectuels ont été arrêtés nous avons
réussi par des renseignements ayant
déjouant la vigilance de nos gardiens à
retrouver l'endroit où ces intellectuels
ont été enfermés cet endroit c'est le
stade de phnom penh et nous avons dit
bien nous voudrions voir le stade de
phnom penh là où le général de gaulle a
fait un discours nous français ça nous
est sensible nous sommes rentrés dans
l'endroit où ça y est vous ces
intellectuels vietnamiens cambodgiens
avaient été enfermés ce sont sept
endroits se sait le les vestiaires de ce
stade et nous avons fait des photos ces
photos où elles vont être publiés dans
la presse nous avons fait des photos de
tous les graffitis qui se trouve sur les
murs des gens qui annoncent que leur
dernière heure va venir en cambodgien
avec des noms avec des phrases en
français
voilà des types de voile a des preuves
voilà des témoignages vous les avez
raisonner avec mary d'hector gamin
capturée aux flambeaux dans plusieurs de
ses chefs lieux de province on sent
qu'ils sont confrontés comme cette star
et qui ont été attribués par la
télévision google sont exsangues à trois
ris s'il vous plaît tant que guide
arbois essaye de nous joueurs car il a
des questions à gauche où vas tu dis
voudrait à part exactement est juste une
petite parenthèse un peu comme l'a fait
jean lacouture effectivement les gens ne
comprennent pas un sur le plan politique
ils ne comprennent pas ils demandent
pourquoi les vietnamiens sont intervenus
et s'ils n'étaient pas intervenues que
serait devenu le cambodge c'est et c'est
exactement ce qu'ils ne comprennent pas
mais toujours sur le plan humanitaire
il y as avant les questions une réaction
que je retrouvais que cette fiche résume
bien
il est indécent 10-10 plusieurs de nos
correspondants il est indécent de
profiter de ce thème pour en faire soit
une tribune politique soit une
compétition commerciale que le débat
nous dit on se recentre sur les
solutions que l'on doit essayer
d'apporter à ce problème
effectivement les gens sont tellement
émue
si en france qu'il demande quoi faire
d'abord il ya unanime une animatrice
d'un centre de réfugiés qui dit que
jusqu'au début du mois de novembre il
arrivait beaucoup de réfugiés mais que
depuis un mois il n'y a malheureusement
plus d'arrivées pour quelles raisons
ne peut-on se rendre sur place pour
rendre service
pourquoi ne peut-on adopter l'un de ses
enfants ou la voir chez soi pendant les
temps difficiles qu'elles font les
démarches à faire pour aider le peuple
cambodgien c'est ce qui intéresse le
plus le public ce soir
écoutez là je crois que je vais donner
la parole à monsieur pinata et qui est
je voulais dit en le présentant tout à
l'heure un des rares rescapés de ce
tragique génocide
je rappelle que monsieur pini hatay a
passé 26 mois dans les camps des khmers
rouges et qu'il est le seul survivant
d'une famille de 18 personnes qui l'y a
perdu sa femme ses enfants son père sa
mère ses frères et c'est ce monsieur
piñata joue dès que non pas que vous
nous racontiez ce que vous avez vécu je
crois que les gens le découvrir en
janvier j'ai lu les épreuves de votre
livre pour vous donner une indication
c'est comparable à ce que nous avons
tous lu sur les connaissent ça n'est pas
pire mais ça n'est pas mieux
je voudrais que vous nous disiez ce que
ce que vous pensez de tout ce qui vient
d'être dit sur la façon dont il convient
d'aider le cambodge et son peuple est
sûre si vous pouvez donner un conseil
en répondant aux gens qui veulent
adopter un enfant cambodgien recueillir
un enfant cambodgien est ce que c'est
souhaitable ou pas c'est toujours ici
pour moi quand je pense à mon pays ça me
fait toujours dans les mains de mes
enfants de ma femme et de mes proches
qui ont été comblés dix mois par la
barbarie des khmers rouges
et maintenant il ya encore les viennent
à mieux qu'ils sont chez nous pour
libérer le peuple cambodgien
c'est ce qu'ils ont dit dès les premiers
venus
ils sont très à tramayes paris vienne
amiens je le conçois et
j'aimerais vraiment que c'est la réalité
mais seulement ça n'a pas duré longtemps
après les taux a reserré et les réfugiés
qui s'entassent encore la frontière
thaïlandaise pour croix si le régime
s'améliore pourquoi il ne reste pas au
cambodge
pourquoi ils sont filles entre landes et
pourquoi il ya tant notre humanité qui
sont proposés internationalement les
médecins tous ont ils ont volontaires
pour partir pour aider le peuple
cambodgien
pourquoi les portes sont fermées si le
bernabeu vraiment aidé le cambodge
il faut qu'il trouve la porte du temps
mort pour que tous les observateurs
étrangers puissent y entrer et regarder
sur place quelle est la barbarie des
khmers rouges et pour sauver aussi le
peuple cambodgien de sa détresse
mais pourquoi resserrer l'étau pour que
les cambodgiens s'enfuit vallée steria
reserrer les taux pour que les étrangers
ne pousse pas venez nous sauver
voilà toutes ces questions je pense la
réponse à évident le vietnam comme
toujours il va avaler le cambodge et les
khmers rouges ont fait le jeu ce sont
les complices objectifs ma famille 18
personnes
je suis l'unique survivant mais combien
de familles qui ont été complètement
décimée à cause de cela comme vous avez
bien dit 95% de temps les classes sont
terminés sont exterminés la formule des
pays à exterminer à cause des khmers
rouges
le rite est fait dans le pays et voilà
que le vietnam arrive je pense tout à
évidence maintenant la question comment
sauver le cambodge
je prends toutes les puissances du monde
qui regarde sans l'europe qui doit
camper a fait son génocide dans le pays
moi même quand j'étais sorti on jette 77
en janvier de 77 j'ai voyagé on peut pas
tout jacques liés au monde
qu'est ce que c'est que le cambodge ont
souri ou bien on lui mais personne à
lyon fait
même le dynario fait le campus et
démocrates n'arrivent toujours le
compotier démocrate et jusqu'au moment
où ils viennent à marie et que voilà la
situation est là je pense la solution
d'après moi comme je vous ai je répète
encore une fois c'est d'ouvrir ses
frontières si le viêt-nam est vraiment
sincère pour aînés le cambodgien
nous l'acceptons amis parce que nous
sommes obligés de vivre côte-à-côte
pourquoi fermer cette peau de tambour
laissez les genres aider et donner une
meilleure vie aux cambodgiens qui pousse
à rester au cambodge
non pas 100 filles en talents et tailler
un costard le problème des réfugiés dans
le monde entier et sion voilà ce que je
pense c'est à dire qu'est ce que vous
voulez répondre à la préoccupation de
nombreux téléspectateurs qui est louable
et et leur dire si vous leur conseillé
d'essayer d'accueillir d'adopter un
petit cambodgien est ce que vous pensez
que c'est une solution sans la une parmi
tant d'autres je pense parce qu'il ya
tellement d'orphelins actuellement à la
frontière des réfugiés qui sont sans
mère son père voyez si vous pouvez
l'adopter je pensais pour cet enfant là
c'est une autre vie des meilleurs
naturellement un jour quand il pourra
rentrer au cambodge
à ce moment là on rentre lance bien
alors ponant roues et je sais que vous
avez manifesté depuis déjà un moment et
je m'en excuse le désir de vous exprimer
oui je voudrais je trouve que dit
monsieur pinata et à la question que se
posait tout à l'heure les
téléspectateurs qu'est ce qui serait
passé au cambodge
si les vietnamiens n'étaient pas
intervenues je crois qu'on peut dire
aujourd'hui si les vietnamiens si les
vietnamiens n'avait pas libéré et je dis
bien entre guillemets le cambodge
je crois qu'il ne resterait plus
aujourd'hui au camp cambodgien à cause
du régime la barbarie absolument
indescriptible des khmers rouges
je voulais aussi à porter très bien très
brièvement mon témoignage
j'ai assisté en mai en mai dernier j'ai
fait un voyage au vietnam et au cambodge
j'ai vu j'assistais au récit de deux
familles comme vous souhaitez absolument
décimer des enfants des femmes des
hommes qui ont été décimés sous les yeux
des parents ça je les ai vus dans les
centaines de camps que j'ai vus autour
de phnom penh ce que je peux dire aussi
c'est que passé ce premier choc si je
puis dire
c'est que dans ces camps qui entourait
phnom penh dans ces centaines de deux
camps qui entouraient la ville de phnom
penh les gens criaient liberté et une
journaliste français sans parler de
confession politique ils criaient
liberté et cette liberté pour le vietnam
d'ici à dire aussi que les vietnamiens
sont en train de faire un génocide au
cambodge pour éliminer le peuple
cambodgien
c'est faux ils n'ont pas intérêt
politiquement est fermé alors attendez
non là là là le moment est venu je crois
d'interroger norodom sihanouk sur tout
ce qui vient d'être dit sur notamment
l'avenir du cambodge les intentions
qu'on prête au vietnam et à qu'est ce
que vous en pensez monseigneur c'est
c'est une question à laquelle il est
difficile de répondre
mais monsieur jean lacouture qui est mon
ami n'a peut-être pas raison de comparer
la colonisation du cambodge à celle pas
par la france à celle du cambodge par le
vietnam
la france est très éloignée
géographiquement du cambodge alors elle
a besoin de main d'oeuvre
et puis la france a des traditions
humanitaire et de liberté à contestable
la france n'auront aucun intérêt
et elle n'a pas l'envi de d'éliminer et
la scamer d'éliminer les cambodgiens
alors la france nous aide a non
seulement à à vivre mais à nous
développer
quand mon arrière grand père le roi
norodom en 1863 à signer
le traité de protectorat avec la france
nous avions un million le cambodge avait
en millions d'habitants et puis quand
j'ai libéré le cambodge en 1953 toute
amitié avec la france nous étions près
de 7 millions donc de 1 million nous
arrivions à voir quand même 7 millions
dont la france a stoppé le processus de
deux mortels de la mortalité oui mais le
processus de la disparition de du
cambodge du fait de deux voisins très
voraces qui ont toujours voulu avaler le
cambodge la thaïlande d'une part et le
virement d'autre part alors la
colonisation via magna elle ne ressemble
pas l'ancien colonisation française au
cambodge le vietnam veut avoir les
terres qui appartiennent aux cambodgiens
pour les paysans vietnamiens qui sont en
surnombre dans maintes régions du
vietnam en particulier au tonkin et je
pense que le vietnam veut naturellement
s'approprier les terres cambodgienne
alors il laisse mourir
les cambodgiens au cambodge où il fait
en sorte que le maximum de cambodgiens
s'enfuit du cambodge hun vers d'autres
cieux
c'est comme ça que vous avez maintenant
sept cent mille cambodgien entre landes
voilà n'est ce pas je crois on ne peut
pas parler de génocide même subtilement
je crois que
c'est ça la situation alors vous vous
avez essayé de prendre contact avec le
gouvernement vietnamien à trois reprises
si j'ai bien noté est ce que vous avez
dit est ce que vous avez dit dimanche à
votre arrivée et la dernière fois où
vous avez écrit affamant donc le
président du gouvernement ils vous à
retourner votre lettre sans même
l'ouvrir c'est ça qu'est ce que ça
signifie
ça signifie que maman dont s'établir son
gouvernement c'est à dire son armée son
pays se croise efforts pour maintenir
leur domination sur le cambodge
définitivement définitivement il rejette
la mise à l'eau qui avait tant aidé les
vietnamiens quand il était dans le
malheur quand il avait à lutter contre
l'impérialisme américain j'ai été
déposée par les pros américains lors
nola particulier la monarchie
cambodgienne bimillénaire a été abolie
par les londoniens
parce que j'avais commis l'erreur de dd
les communistes vietnamiens je leur
accorder une multitude dead une aide
multiforme et pourquoi c'est parce que
les viandes amiens n'est ce pas
je savais que les communistes
vietnamiens allait gagner la guerre
tôt ou tard il il gagnerait cette guerre
alors n'est ce pas je voulais que après
la victoire d'amiens sur les américains
en indochine les biens l'amiens respecte
l'indépendance l'intégrité territoriale
les frontières terrestres et maritimes
de ma patrie je voulais avoir à capital
non pas 200 partie des biens en bien en
mal de reconnaissance
pour mon pays et c'est ce qui est arrivé
pendant les années 60 et 70
havas dont vos murs fiable et wan et ce
sera tout ou le directoire leadership
vietnamiens anouilh mans jurés m'ont
promis qu' ils respecteraient
l'indépendance l'intégrité territoriale
les frontières maritimes et terrestres
de moi cambodge mais après quand
messieurs les khmers rouges leur ont
permis en créer toutes les conditions
voulues pour que le virement colonise
mon pays alors le virement
se croyant assez fort pour maintenir son
protectorat et son colonialisme sur le
cambodge à l'eau il n'a pas besoin du
site social ou excusez moi mais ce pas
je respecte le communisme chinois je
respecte le communisme nord-coréen
parce que je suis l'hôte de la chine
l'hôte soyez de du président comme ils
sont mais il me semble que les
communistes ne st pas ce que c'est que
un engagement d'honneur l'honneur ce qui
est moral ce qui est immoral
les communistes ne font pas la
différence n'est ce pas ce n'est pas une
question qui intéresse les communistes
je ne parle pas des chinois des non
croyants non non non parce que je suis
là amis et je ne suis pas un drap en
tant que bouddhiste
je cultive la gratitude mais si je en
regardant vers les autres communistes
ils sont immoraux or ou plutôt un
brouhaha
c est ce que les vietnamiens ne vous en
veulent pas d'avoir permis aux khmers
rouges de se mettre en selle au pouvoir
quand vous étiez avec le président de la
république en 1964 et en leur reprochant
à m est pro chinois c'est vous qui avait
mis les que les khmers rouges au pouvoir
75 voulez vous étiez président de la
république et il était ministre
et alors les chinois les vietnamiens
sachant que ce sont des pros chinois
vous en veulent à vous de les avoir
installés non en envoyant vraiment
attendez attendez en 1976 par le podium
sa vie ont reçu une délégation féminine
bien la mienne
hanoi dirigée par la présidente de
l'association des femmes démocratique
vient d'amiens c'est à dire la femme
numéro un du verlan communiste alors
n'est ce pas cette délégation avait des
louanges dithyrambiques dithyrambique du
régime de poteaux et puis attaqué très
sauvagement mon régime en disant que
dans l'ancienne société ce qu'ils
appellent en cambodgien le sac contient
et bien les femmes n'étaient pas les
égales des hommes les femmes 2 juil
c'est donc à pouvoir alors que c'était
le contraire et nous les avions ces
mêmes femmes bien la mienne reçu à bras
ouverts
quand j'étais chef des pins dans les
années 50 et 60
il venait souvent n'aura promise elle
venait souvent de me rendre visite elle
le faisait aussi des loirs jeu
dithyrambique de mon régime
mais voyant que et une série nominés le
combo sur les biens damien l'aller chez
les sandales en face visons les
standards au tibet ou bien n'est-ce pas
pourquoi voulez-vous que il me reproche
d'être d'avoir misé en scène les les
les khmers rouges alors que eux mêmes
n'est ce pas ils ont toujours soutenu
louangé les khmers rouges
jusqu'au jour où l'escroc mer rouge sont
allés les égorger égorger leurs villages
war n'est ce pas au sud via nan parce
que comme madison scène en 1976 au début
de 76,60 vice premier ministre chargé de
la défense nationale me dit vous savez
un mets mes soldats gg ennuis avec mes
soldats parce que ils ont vu avec leurs
jumelles d'épargné à sucre au camp pu
dire quand c'est à dire on ne souvient
pas n'est ce pas il est théoriquement
quand on entre au cambodge à partir du
vietnam on trouve d'épargné à sucre et
or vient de là il n'y a pas de pamiers à
sucre en principe mais en vérité il ya
d'épargné à sucre 1 on subira alors les
soldats khmers rouges disent que puisque
via l'épargné en sucre aussi bien c'est
que le subiet appartient au cambodge
clore là ils ont foncé
ils sont allés faire leurs pratiques
avant pratiquer leur génocide classique
au détriment des vietnamiens et c'est
comme ça que les vietnamiens ont riposté
et alors vous voyez vous n'est ce pas
comme l'a dit un professeur cambodgien
interviewé par une les chaînes de la
télévision française tout dernièrement
au cambodge ce professeur be et les
khmers rouges sont à led égorger les
liens à miel et bien amir en
contre-attaqué et ils sont allés jusqu'à
la frontière polonaise alors on avait
voulu
n'est ce pas prendre une partie des
civières main pour le cambodge mais le
résultat est que les biens damiron prix
ont conquis tout le cameroun on
appréciera permettez une toute petite
intervention dans ce que vous avez dit
vous savez très bien et on a en a
longtemps discuté ensemble notamment à
new york que toute l'ambiguïté en ce
moment et les réactions vietnamienne c
explique aussi par votre présence aux
côtés des khmers rouges pendant le
génocide du peuple comme cambodgien par
ces mêmes que les rouges de 75 à 79
si votre présence là bas toute
l'ambiguïté de la situation c'est que
vous les avez aidé pas aidé est ce que
vous étiez d'accord pas d'accord au
courant pas au courant alors vous vous
les regardez vous me le permettez de
parler ou quelqu'un d'autre veut parler
à mano si vous voulez après vous
répondrais monseigneur ainsi un argument
à l'égard des vietnamiens qui est assez
fort qui est actuellement le chef du
gouvernement supposé gouvernement à
phnom penh
c'est monsieur samrin qui est un grand
dirigeant khmer rouge c'est à dire
qu'est ce qu'on fait les vietnamiens ils
ont mis au pouvoir à phnom penh
actuellement l'homme le commandant de la
4ème armée khmers rouges qui pendant
quatre ans a été un des massacreurs du
peuple cambodgien
ils s'asseyent singulier de reprocher à
des adéens temps de charge d avoir été
quelques temps avec les khmers rouges
alors qu'eux mêmes ont installé au
pouvoir actuellement un des grands chefs
khmers rouges c'est comme si à
libération de l'allemagne en 1945
nous avions mis au pouvoir fin de
ribennes drop rudolf hess et le maréchal
von paulus n'est ce pas c'est tout de
même singulier alors ils sont eux mêmes
complices de ce qu'on admette n'y
actuellement un grand khmers rouges à la
direction du cambodge de journée leur
écoute
en effet en effet je commence moi qui ne
suis pas un expert et j'imagine que
beaucoup de téléspectateurs sont dans
mon cas à mélanger un peu beaucoup de
choses voulez-vous jean lacouture
puisque vous aviez la parole nous dire
de façon aussi succincte que possible ce
que sont les khmers ou leur organisation
leur philosophie et pourquoi
en quelques phrases iso pratiquer ce
génocide c'est un point important que
nous aimerions connaître je parle sous
le contrôle de gens qui sont tout
naturellement présents s'ils n'ont plus
compétents que moi je pense que au
départ les khmers rouges c'est un groupe
de jeunes intellectuels cambodgiens qui
sont venus faire leurs études en france
pour la plupart au début des années 50
il y avait là un certain nombre de gens
qui ont fait certains des études
supérieures comme que sans panne ou
youn qui ont fait des études de doctorat
à l'université parisienne et qui étaient
ces jeunes intellectuels de gauche venus
de l'empiré français qui ont formé des
gens comme ben barka ou comme la plupart
des dirigeants tunisiens marocains ou
d'afrique noire et ils ont constitué un
plus ou moins parti communiste qui se
tape les parties du peuple pratique
yonne où d'autres d'autres formes
le problème chez eux a été que ce parti
supposé communiste personnel en fait je
mets beaucoup de doutes sur le caractère
maxis de cette organisation qui me
paraît purement raciste mais en tout cas
ils avaient donc cette organisation
révolutionnaire se réclamant plus ou
moins du marxisme leur grand problème a
été que certains d'entre eux pensaient
qu'il devait faire route commune avec
les vietnamiens que l'organisation
révolutionnaire vietnamienne était le
grand frère et que autour de chi minh
il fallait me faire monter en s'appuyant
sur la grande puissance communiste
vietnamien le communisme cambodgien et
un autre groupe
celui qui avait le pouvoir dans les
vietnamiens les ont renversé sont
essentiellement du comice un
nationaliste qui pensaient que les
vietnamiens sur les gens les
colonisateurs et que tout le mouvement
révolutionnaire que mr devaient être
braqués contre les vietnamiens que
c'était en fait l'adversaire peut-être
pas immédiate mais à long terme et il y
a eu conflit entre ces deux courants le
courant pro vietnamiens et le courant
anti vietnamien s'est apparemment plutôt
les antilles vietnamien qui l'ont
emporté quand ils ont formé des maquis
contre le gouvernement du principe nous
et après contre l'invasion américaine
c'est les ultra nationalistes 7 e ssom
panne c'est paul potts essonne seine
déjà qu'ils ont qui l'ont emporté et qui
ont créé à ce moment là un régime qui
est assez qui a guère de précédent dans
l'histoire
sinon c'est qu'on pourrait appeler une
caricature de la banque des quatre
chinoises n'est ce pas à supposer
d'imaginer que cette bande des cats
auraient été isolé dans la forêt je
crois qu'un des grands phénomènes de la
folie de la folie de la démence des
khmers rouges celle isolement celle
isolement qui ressemble un peu à celui
du pasteur jim jones qui a dans la forêt
de guyane fait massacrer 1 400 personnes
les à l'est la persuader de ce massacre
et je crois que c'est un phénomène
d'isolement
il ya aussi un phénomène de de
contradictions profondes entre un groupe
d'intellectuels formé à l'origine à
l'occidentale ici à paris et des gens de
la forêt qui étaient des gens de très
peu de formation ce n'est pas de leur
faute s'ils n'avaient pas été à l'école
et pour unir ces intellectuels venus
d'une capitale occidentale et des gens
venus de la forêt parlant même peut-être
pas exactement le khmer n'est ce pas et
il fallait y lit avec quelle était la
façon de souder c'était la violence et
l'ultra violence dans l'ultra violence
tout le monde peut se reconnaître
l'intellectuel comme le type qui n'est
pas allé à l'école ils ont formé cette
ce moment sur les bases ultra
nationalistes et même raciste en voulant
revenir à la grandeur tout à fait
authentique du peuple khmer d'autrefois
sur des bases ultra nationaliste raciste
l'enfermement total qu'ils avaient
subies malgré eux dans la forêt ils ont
eu l'imposer à l'ensemble de leurs
peuples
quand ils ont pris le pouvoir tout ça
aboutit à ce régime ultra nationaliste
hyper nationaliste raciste et qui a
considéré qu'ils devaient pour créer
l'homme nouveau cambodgien massacrer
tous qui avez eu un rapport quelconque
avec l'occident que intellectuelle semi
intellectuelle techniciens de gens comme
monsieur piñata y pardon tout cela
devait disparaître tout cela c'était
l'homme l'homme de la civilisation
moderne européenne et occidentale et
qu'il fallait substituer un homme sorti
de la rizière l'homme du grain de riz
l'homme qui était légal du grain de riz
on mentionne le monde le monde ancien
car dans cette révolution curieuse
l'ancien peuple été confiée comme aux
nouveaux peuples comme nounou mauvais
n'est ce pas et voilà je sais en
quelques phrases jeunes auxquels je vous
remercie de denain explique un de ceux
de la scène que ce raccourci n'y est
très ouverte
alors maintenant je voulais interroger
un monsieur shawcross parce que c'est
ici que se situe son intervention à un
moment charnière de l'histoire du
cambodge
vous pensez vous dites dans votre
ouvrage monsieur shawcross que si les
khmers rouges sont arrivés au pouvoir et
que s'ils ont exterminé bonne moitié le
peuple cambodgien
tout ça c'est au départ la faute ou une
erreur commise par nixon et le docteur
qui suggère
j'ai pas dis que c'est tout ça je suis
d'accord avec jean lacouture pas sur les
origines des khmers rouges
ce que j'ai dit c'est que en 1966 quand
le prince inouk avait sa chute de
pouvoir les khmers rouges mais avec eux
peut-être quatre millions de 4000 de
gens c'était un maquis à ses piques à
ses petits il n'avait aucune espoir de
pouvoir politique
il n'avait aucune espoir de prendre le
pouvoir de tout le cambodge
mais après cinq années de la guerre de
la guerre des américains au cambodge
quand les américains ont soutenu le
régime corrompu de lol après ces cinq
années
d'abord toute la société cambodgien
était détruit déjà il y avait trois
millions de gens entre 7 millions qui
s'enfuit de la rizière de la paysage aux
villes il y avait eu l'emballement est
absolument énorme de toutes les rizières
par les américains et je crois que par
les américains en kayak réagi aucun
bouge dans une façon qui qui était pas
mesuré et que après cinq années là si
vous voulez la stabilité du peuple
cambodgien du tutu société comme d'un
show cambodia étaient détruits déjà
elecam les khmers rouges ce moment là en
75 maintenant ils n'étaient pas il était
plus 4000
il était vers 60 75 mille et une armée
assez petit théo toujours mais très fort
très cruel et ils ont la région de long
elle était très con rendre plus les
soldats étaient très courageux disons
mais le régime va tomber et les khmers
rouges en on a donné les clés rouge la
pouvoir et je pense que la faute des
américains à ses jours c'est surtout le
foot kissinger parce que ils avaient des
très bons américains de l'ambassade à
washington qui a donné des conseils à il
faut pas faire ça avec un bold cambodia
il faut pas amener cette petite guerre
dans la guerre du vietnam et tout ça il
notes après cet avis c'étaient les
conditions dans lesquelles les khmers
rouges ont pris le pouvoir ça c'était la
faute et cette guerre c'est un peu comme
les bolcheviks en russe les bolcheviks
n'aurait pu pour n'aurait pas pu prendre
le pouvoir
sauf avec le destruction de la première
guerre mondiale
c'est ça avec les khmers rouges aussi à
mon avis et ce n'était pas la faute de
principe nous comme vous avez dit que le
vietnam en vietnamien pourrait dire je
crois que peut-être le prince lui-même
dirait maintenant que il aurait mieux ne
pas se mettre avec les khmers rouges
après 60 66 après son échec mais je
crois que l'heure quand on parle de la
réalité du cambodge c'est à nous qui a
compris qu'un petit pays de 7 millions
ne peut pas jamais battre contre le
vietnam de 50 millions l'on note et les
américains n'ont pas compensé n'ont pas
compris ça pendant qu répète non plus
merci guy d'arbois vous avez la parole
je sais que j'ai encore beaucoup de
questions à se soumettre et bien je
crois qu'il faut revenir un ses
critiques qui ont été adressées au
prince hier justement monseigneur
l'accusé on ne me permet pas de répondre
aux accusations que vous voulez bien est
ce que vous voulez bien prendre la
parole et répondre à 6 3 je vous
remercie à ces trois critiques
la première c'est pourquoi avez vous
appuyer les khmers rouges dans leur
prise de pouvoir
la deuxième c est ce que vous avez été
au courant ou non de cette entreprise de
génocide qui était la leur et la
troisième pourquoi vous êtes vous
réfugier en chine alors que les chinois
soutiennent encore aujourd'hui polpot et
les khmers rouges
bon alors tout d'abord je réponds en
tant qu'accusé sur un banc des accusés
j'ai toujours été contre toutes les
puissances qui menace l'indépendance de
mon pays j'aime la france de tout mon
coeur je laime passionnément
je suis de culture française c'est la
france qui m'a fait froid mais pourtant
j'ai lutté contre la france parce que je
ne pouvais mettre le colonialisme
français sur mon pays j'ai lutté contre
la france mais je n'ai pas voulu que le
sang français coup là j'ai réussi
miraculeusement en 1953 à réaliser une
indépendance complète pour mon pays avec
l'accord de paris
c'était tant mieux pour moi mais ensuite
les américains ont voulu néo-colonisés
mon pays
comme ils ont néo-colonisés le superman
violent les accords de genève de 1951 et
selon ces accords il devait y avoir en
1956 juillet 1956 deux mois exactement
mois pour mois des élections générales
permettant au vietnam de d'être
réunifiés soit sous nos d'indium ou
autres soient souvent timides proteam il
devait gagner haut la main cette
sélection on n'a pas permis à continuer
de gagner je trouve que c'est injuste
communiste ou non ils avaient le droit
de participer aux élections et s'il
devait gagner ces élections
il devait vouloir réunifier son pays
libérer le sud vietnam de l'impérialisme
américain
quitte à faire du vietnam un virement
communiste mais ça ne doit pas nous
intéresser
ce qui nous intéresse c'est la justice
c'est le respect des accords de genève
aucun en sus souscrit là
france la grande bretagne et autres
alors ce qui concerne mon pays je ne
veux pas que mon pays soit une néo
colonie de l'impérialisme a enfin les
états unis d'amérique les l'on nomme les
séries matin boulet cela c'est pourquoi
je me suis disputé
dans les années 60 avec ces gens là et
ils m'ont déposé
c'est ainsi que je me suis alliés aux
khmers rouges qui à cette époque n'était
pas connue comme étant des amateurs de
génocide
personne ne pouvait imaginer qu'ils
fussent des gens capables de commettre
de tels horaires de tels crimes
personne personne ni les français ni les
autres en france on ne soupçonnait pas
cela il faut pas jeter la pierre sur
jean lacouture sur les gauchistes
français seulement
mais les autres non plus ne pouvait pas
penser que les khmers rouges puces des
monstres personne ne pouvait le savoir
on savait que bruissent carlo fois
pouvait retarder les monstre
frankenstein etc
mais je ne savais pas que monsieur parle
pas et est un monstre qu'on ne savait
pas que monsieur x harry était un
monstre qu'on me jette la première
pierre celui qu'il me jette la première
pierre celui qui m'accuse
aujourd'hui est-ce que celui là n'est ce
pas ils savaient ce qu'était les khmers
rouges
même le 17 avril 1975 quand les khmers
rouges sont entrés dans prenons pain il
y avait des câbles kim était parvenu à à
pékin geoffrey une réception pour fêter
notre notre victoire au corps
diplomatique tout le monde venait me
féliciter y compris les ambassadeurs
occidentaux
les ambassadeurs du monde libre soit
mise en attaché aux droits de l'homme et
ses câbles que disent-ils
ce n'était pas des tables de la chance
tu as ce n'était pas des câbles de
xinhua
c'était des câbles
afp c'était des câbles retard c'étaient
des câbles à société prince united press
internet mans et bien il disait tout ce
que les khmers rouges étaient gentilles
qu'il promenait les journalistes dans
des jeeps et strike on fait tous
fêtaient la victoire n'est ce pas
les journalistes américains fêter la
victoire avec les khmers rouges mais
quelques heures après ça a été la
désillusion mais avoir sur la personne
mais c'est la vérité mais moi je n'avais
aucune idée de ce qui se passait nessma
chez moi à part les câbles bon mais
mettez vous à ma place
est-ce que vous préféreriez laisse pas
vivre en exil ou rentrez chez vous n'est
ce pas il y a des gens qui sont restés
avec pétards pendant la guerre parce que
ils sont attachés au sol de la france il
n'y a pas que des collaborateurs qui
sont restés en france pendant la seconde
guerre mondiale quand la france était
occupée par les les
l'équipe derrière les allemands de
kittler jeu
j'ai la nostalgie de mon pays à l'heure
actuelle aussi je veux rentrer chez moi
je souffre je suis humilié quand on dit
que je suis à l'exil et que je suis à un
lâche qui n'osent pas rentrer au
cambodge
si je n'arrive pas à libérer mon pays je
vous assure que je rentrais même si mon
pays colonisés par le vietnam
s'il repart aussitôt rabia mien je
rentrerai dans mon pays dans un an dans
deux ans mais je ne ferai pas ce que moi
ma place n'est ni à paris ni à pékin ni
à combien ma place est au cambodge
maintenant je vais essayer de faire
quelque chose pour amener le vietnam
ah non pas à canossa mai à genève pour
essayer dans le cadre d'une nouvelle
conférence sur l'indochine de récupérer
mon cambodge
c'est à dire de rétablir au cambodge
l'indépendance et la neutralité
ce sera cambodge à mittal avait tous
avec la chine mais aussi avec l'union
soviétique avec le vietnam
ce qui pourrait donner à mon cambodge la
stabilité et la sécurité avec en donnant
satisfaction aux deux camps qui se
disputent le cambodge
à l'heure actuelle alors n'est ce pas je
suis rentré au cambodge
vous savez les tout d'abord j'ai demandé
à rentrer immédiatement au cambodge mais
les premières rouge
ils ne m'ont pas permis ne voulait pas
de cyrano alors j'ai demandé au
président comme ils sont de négocier
avec les khmers rouges
mon entrée au cambodge ce n'est qu'après
vous savez un nous gagnons la guerre en
avril à la ce n'est qu'en septembre que
les khmers rouges m'ont permis de
rentrer je suis rentré je suis rentré au
cambodge
je ne savais même pas que les khmers
rouges devaient passer ces mois pendant
lesquels ils me laissaient en dehors du
cambodge pour éliminer les cyrano kyste
il voulait d'abord éliminer les sirènes
ou kyste avant de faire rentrer si à
nous alors quand je suis rentré n'y
avait plus de six analystes
je ne savais pas parce que je ne voyais
personne a applaudi ce loyer bien simple
alors on m'a fait voir ensuite des gens
dans la campagne je n'ai pas vu de
génocide
je n'ai pas vu de gens qui étaient
maigres squelettiques
je n'avais pas vu de gens malades on m'a
menée dans des chantiers où les gens
étaient bien portants où les gens
étaient souriants et vous savez ce qui
s'est passé entre 1976 et ma libération
en janvier 1979 par la chine est aussi
indirectement par le vietnam qui
envahissent et le cambodge alors sur les
conseils de la chine pour le pape devait
se servir de moi pour défendre la le
cambodge ont envahi par le vietnam au
conseil de sécurité à new york
mais entre 76 et 79 laisse pas on me
promet le temps à autre dans une des
usines dans des bourgades et non
à la campagne surtout dans les
coopératives laisse pa nou peuple au
lieu de me reprocher d'être avec les
khmers rouges se sentent et réconfortés
par ma présence
il se disait le prince aurait pu être à
pyongyang dans son palais aurait pu être
à pékin dans son palais aurait pu être à
paris va il a préféré l prisonniers de
popote avec nous c'est ce que le peuple
m'a toujours dit chaque fois que
j'allais là-bas le peuple disait merci
merci d'être avec nous merci d'être avec
nous voyez vous n'est ce pas même si je
soupçonnais les khmers rouges d'être
cruciale je sentais que j'étais utile à
mon peuple je devais partager les joies
et les peines de mon peuple j'ai déjà
demandé trois ou quatre fois à la
thaïlande par l'intermédiaire d'un
ancien ambassadeur très demandé à
l'opecst n'est ce pas la permission pour
la triland de de balai dans un camp de
réfugiés en thaïlande réfugiés
cambodgiens avec ma femme et vivre avec
des réfugiés
les thaïlandais ne m'ont pas encore
répondu il n'y a pas que pendant dont
qui me rejette mais la très longue aussi
me rejette la très longue
on pose à mais demande à mes requêtes
qui sont nombreuses à refus mais
supposer que demain ou après demain
la très longue des princes et à l'eau
vous avez la permission de vivre votre
vie de réfugié dans un temps de
réveiller je vous assure que je pars que
parier je m'en vais avec ma femme me
mettre à la disposition des réfugiés non
pas à la disposition
c'est à dire à me mettre avec les
réfugiés dans un camp de réfugiés vie
voir le couple a même vie que les
réfugiés
voila voila ma conception de de mon
patriotisme
alors quand vous êtes la pierre n'est ce
pas non alors est ce qu'il ya une autre
question oui oui ajoute question mon
seigneur qui sont celles ci et quand
avez vous été mise au courant du
no 6 comment avez vous découvert saint
jean une deuxième je vous poserai oui
n'est ce pas il ya des gens qui trouvent
que c'est bien de raccrocher à cyano
mais avec des khmers rouges mais ils
n'ont pas souffert dans leur sens ils
n'ont pas souffert dans leur bille parce
qu'ils n'ont pas perdu l'espoir de
parents et n'ont pas perdu d'enfants et
n'ont pas perdu de petits enfants aux
mains des khmers rouges
j'ai perdu trois filles deux fils de
jean brun 14 petits-enfants
il n'y a qu'une fille qui était avec
celui matin et non les autres y compris
les petits enfants étaient tous dans le
front uni national du cambout tir front
uni à vis des khmers rouges
alors après notre victoire commune
cassettes et de l'histoire commune des
hameaux kystique mer rouge alors ils
sont rentrés volontairement au cas
bourges il n'étais pas communiste
au contraire il était très royaliste
mais il estimait que rouge ou non le
camp bausch était leur parti et que la
france si belle si hospitalière soit 1
ce n'est pas notre patrie la chine non
plus n'est pas notre patrie alors nous
sommes rentrés ensemble les khmers
rouges
les ont fait disparaître alors un
jeunesse eut enfin j'ai su que ils
étaient massacrés par les khmers rouges
oui quand j'étais au cambodge des khmers
rouges disait qu' il était bien ça et
sauf dans des coopératives
mais il ya des réfugiés qui ont réussi à
s'enfuir de l'enfant a enfin à fuir
l'enfer cambodgien très récemment et ils
m'écrivent ils me disent nos enfants nos
petits-enfants ont tous étaient moins
sacré par les khmers rouges parce qu'ils
étaient dans les mêmes coopérative que
nous on les a amenés on les a fusillé on
les a massacrés alors c'est comme ça que
j'ai su même à propos de mes enfants et
de mes petits enfants
alors comment voulez vous que je puisse
savoir sur ce qui se passe chez mon
peuple j'ai mon peuple
au point que mes enfants mais je cite
l'exemple de mes enfants pourquoi
parce que mes enfants c'est ma chère et
c'est mon sens alors n'est ce pas qu'on
comprenne bien pourquoi je suis resté au
coach je suis resté par solidarité avec
mon peuple j'ai des enfants j'ai perdu
mes enfants est ce que quelqu'un peut
dire qu'il a souffert autant que moi mon
voisin de gauche le monseigneur oui oui
non non j'ai eus ensemble bat sedan sur
ping a trahi et moi nous sommes ensemble
lui il m'a écrit mon seigneur voulait
bien répondre à la troisième case je
sais pas parce que je suis vieux j'aime
j'oublie les questions alors je suis un
élément d'applications appelée moi je
les ai noté pourquoi avoir choisi
d'aller en chine alors que les chinois
s'y tenait et soutiennent encore les
khmers rouges savez je répète que je
suis bouddhiste
je cultive la gratitude juin l'aïe a
beaucoup fait pour moi et pour ma mère
ma mère longue et nixon refusé de 2,2 me
renvoyer renvoyer auprès de moi ma mère
quand j'étais à pékin dans les années
1970 75 c'est tout en live après vous
savez les accords de genève
alors excusez moi de changer de sens
rails avec nixon manier la lune de miel
à toute nouvelle en c'était en 1973
quelque chose comme ça je n'ai pas la
mémoire des dates
eh bien je dis tu vois là il s'il vous
plaît vous êtes maman bien avec les
américains bill ward faire pression sur
le nombre pour qu'il me rende ma mère
c'est comme ça que j'ai pu avoir ma mère
en 73 et elle est morte dix jours après
la victoire du 17 avril 1975 c'est à
dire elle est morte le 27 avril
gdo chinois vous savez vous avez fait
pour moi beaucoup beaucoup énormément et
je suis très reconnaissant je serai
toujours avec vous je ne vous
abandonnerai jamais je vous soutiendrai
toujours si vous dans l'avenir
vous avez besoin de moi je suis toujours
prêt à répondre à votre appel
alors j'avais voulu
après après la voie à défendre un mon
pays contre l'invasion vietnamienne au
conseil de sécurité rangeons janvier
j'ai même demandé demandé où était de
barman j'ai même chose curieuse ironie
du sort si vous voulez n'est ce pas j'ai
envoyé une requête au gouvernement
américain demandant l'asile politique
possible à nous et sa famille en
amérique au je n'ai pas de complexe j'ai
vaincu l'amérique avec les khmers rouges
alors je peux bien demandé à l'amérique
de m'héberger alors alors après après il
nous a répondu monseigneur la mairie
glee je suis prêt je suis pas deux mais
ma femme dit la france est notre petite
villa de mougins c'est mieux alors
finalement jeudi bonbons parce que vous
savez on dit que ma femme exerce une
certaine influence sur moi
enfin on ne sait pas votre femme exerce
toujours une certaine influence sur vous
n'est ce pas enfin soyons galant n'est
ce pas alors ma femme me dit en amérique
nous sommes en pays inconnu en france
nous sommes en pays connu alors s'il
vous plaît mougins clos alors un
mouchard jeudi bon bon ton fait pas
alors maintenant je jeudi aux américains
à plus tard mon asile politique à la je
vais demander à mes berger blanc
sam and therapy en amérique et hrp me
demande un rendez-vous il me dit tracy
rannou s'il vous plaît ne faites pas ces
choses là
allez plutôt vivre en chine vous avez
toujours dit que la chine est votre
seconde patrie c'est votre ami numéro
alors votre ami numéro 1 demande que
vous alliez en pékin plutôt qu'en france
à la france est à votre ami numéro deux
alors je dis bon d'accord si vous avez
besoin de moi je vais en en chine
et vous savez vous vous savez ce qui se
passe moi j'ai je suis très durs à
l'égard de machines georges laraque tout
le temps
je n'attaque tellement avec une telle
violence au sujet de son accointance
avec polpot que les russes ont fini par
dire à tout le monde vous savez c'est
une comédie que les chinois ont ordonné
à 6 à nous de jouer non je ne suis pas
de comédie j'attaque les chinois parce
que je trouve que ce que font les
chinois c'est mauvais et je continue à
le dire à ce qui concerne la croissance
de la chine avec ce régime
insoutenable de palpable mais ceci dit
les stars il n'y a pas que la chine qui
est à reprocher à l'eau année on veut
toujours pour bordeaux et dernièrement
j'ai vu même l'ambassadeur lui marre de
vous trotte il ya quelques jours avant
de venir à paris
il l'a fait une confession devant ses
collaborateurs devant ma femme nous
avions un ter l'ambassade d'amérique
vous de coca a fini par m'avouer parce
que je critique et aussi les états unis
d'amérique et les pays occidentaux
à part la france qui a voté à bissau et
qui s'est abstenu de voter ni pour cs
bruges hip hop hop hop enfin à la france
a très bien fait et je l'en félicite
les autres ont voté avec la chine pour
paul pope pour que paul pope occupent le
siège du cambodge à l'onu j'ai dit à ces
gens là où fait du racisme anti blanc et
projets je suis à job mais je n'accepte
pas cette injustice quand les blancs
commettaient des crimes qu'on les pende
est sigler les maxi voit le maréchal
cayton von ribbentrop et ce sera alors
le von ribbentrop super hitlérien iront
sa vie lui
on l'applaudît à l'ol lui on l'applaudît
dans toutes les conférences
internationales
on a beau me monsieur tourner personnes
et cette rage même ville des draps de
lambil dollar croix rouge etc
on les applaudit voyez c'est du racisme
blanc anti s'établir les blancs sont
racistes anti blancs et projets vous
voyez vous voilà dans la mare ô seigneur
est ce que vous savez le temps qui nous
reste
je vais vous poser une du mal je suis
l'accusé il faut bien que j'avais louge
et nous avait répondu la question est
celle-ci vous êtes sur nos terres vous
avez dit non le nom vous allez répondre
à celle ci vous avez dit tout à l'heure
je ne veux pas ramener le vietnam à
canossa mais à une nouvelle conférence
de genève or la situation est la
suivante vous avez contre vous le
vietnam est son protecteur l'union
soviétique
vous avez pas pour vous la chine qui
soutient toujours les khmers rouges
les etats-unis ont l'air tout à fait
indifférent comment allez vous vous y
prendre pour rendre à votre pays la
liberté d'une part et d'autre part
essayer de lui donner un gouvernement
démocratique
je n'ai pas beaucoup d'illusions
beaucoup d'espoir mais vous savez les
cambodgiens qui sont dans les camps des
réfugiés en thaïlande quand ils ne sont
pas claires rouge ceux qui sont en
france aux états unis et dans le monde
ils me disent s'il vous plaît n'est ce
pas accepté de mener une lutte une lutte
politique diplomatique vie mais une
lutte aussi militaire contre les
vietnamiens jeudi une lutte militaire ce
n'est pas raisonnable ils disent non
nous sommes nous savons que nous ne
gagnerons pas la guerre contre l'armée
bien la mienne qui est trop forte pour
nous mais il faudrait créer plus de
difficultés au virement pour l'amener à
genève à une conférence internationale
parce que le vietnam fait face à des
difficultés croissantes de toutes sortes
au vietnam au laos et au cambodge en
acier ont créé un peu plus de
difficultés au vietnamien alors ceci
pourrait pourrait
c'est au conditionnel laisse pas
ensemble et à genève pour s'en sortir la
tête haute parce que avec cyrano qui
n'est pas virna mob le vienna pourrait
peut-être accepté vous voyez un cambodge
à rendre accepté de rendre la liberté au
cambodge mais ceux ci un mec à l'espoir
est mince espoir mais voyez-vous les
canadiens hier m'ont demandé pourquoi je
voulais faire couler plus de 100
cambodgien jeudi au canadien ce aussi
supposer que les russes amène chez vous
l'armée russe naturellement est
imbattable au canada ce n'est pas le
canada à l'armée canadienne qui va
pouvoir un espace se débarrasser de
l'armée russe
à supposer qu'elle ramène au canada et
qu'elle occupe le canada mais est ce que
en tant que patriote vous les canadiens
vous ne prendriez par les armes pour
faire quelques coups des coups de feu
n'est ce pas contre contre les russes
vous laisseriez les russes occupent est
comme ça impunément sans que vous vous
résistiez au moins sauver l'honneur
prenez une équipe de football qui est
battu par l'autre sets à 0 1
alors quand il reste cinq minutes avant
la fin le coup de sifflet final
on essaie quand même de faire un but
pour sauver l'honneur voilà l'esprit
dans lequel je travaille c'est
désespérant mais c'est comme ça nous
sommes donc dans une situation
désespérée mais c'est aux autres c'est
aux états unis 7 à la chine c'est aux
autres tous les pays qui votent pour
paul pope de se dire que polpot n'a pas
d'avenir il faudrait quand même faire
autre chose que pour que de rester et
d'une façon incompréhensible et même
blâmable avec mon pote main mais vous
savez il n'ya pas que la chine qui est
blâmable quai qui est à blâmer les états
unis tout le monde tous ceux qui ont
voté pour porter à l'onu est ailleurs et
ailleurs sont à blâmer sera sont à
blâmer
ils font cus
changent leur attitude docteur juste un
mot par excusez moi j'ai excusez moi ben
je suis pourtant allé très vite
si je résume m a pensé vous me fait
beaucoup de peine mon seigneur parce que
je j'ai vécu plusieurs semaines avec
votre peuple
est ce que vous venez de dire ici c'est
un peu arrêté d'apporter un bon peuple
des médicaments importés lui des fusils
et je voudrais vous dire très
sincèrement ce dont a besoin votre
peuple aujourd'hui c'est d'une aide
d'une aide matérielle et aussi d'une
aide humaine y compris de la vôtre vite
compris de la vôtre je la vis dans mes
discours dans mes déclarations je donne
la priorité absolue à l'aide humanitaire
docteur vous demandez des fusillades
dans le peuple
reconnaissez la vie commence à renaître
les on parlait des réfugiés tout à
l'heure en thaïlande
vous savez bien que ces réfugiés
installés en thaïlande ce ne sont pas
des réfugiés ou selon temps ce sont des
cambodgiens qui viennent de sortir de
l'enfer mais rouge et qui sont refoulés
encore par les khmers rouges en
thaïlande
vous savez bien que ce sont sa vie
réfugier en thaïlande et votre road pop
et commence à renaître votre peuple
commence à renaître nous l'avons vu
renaître qu'on lui apportent toute
l'aide dont il a besoin et qu'on lui
apporte plus la guerre il vient de vivre
pire que ce qui s'est passé dans les
camps nazis qu'on lui donne aussi j'ai
des remords et pas des fusils surtout
pas des fûts je vous réponde un mot
norodom sihanouk a dit dimanche en
arrivant à paris nous ne ferons pas la
guerre aux khmers rouges
vous l'avez dit où enseigne un bon donc
il n'est pas question de guerre un
medley de de l'offensive diplomatique si
je vais approprient père ponchaud et
puis ce sera presque tout je pense que
la guerre a suffisamment duré que le
centre cambodgien a suffisamment coulé
en dépit de tout ce qu'on vous reproche
princier nous régler en partie justifiée
du moins ce que les cambodgiens que je
fréquente vous reproche je pense une
grande partie pour eux vous êtes un
symbole et sur vos épaules pause repose
le poids de leur avenir
saurez-vous autour de votre personne
rassembler les patriotes cambodgiens qui
luttent contre l'occupation de leur pays
et je vous le souhaite beaucoup de
quelques patriotes pour que nos cités
comme sur saône 5 on a vu tout à l'heure
la télévision se seront écartés de vous
on peut le regretter
ils ont peur qu'un retour de votre part
un tête du carbone soit un retour aux
méthodes de gouvernement passé j'espère
que la solution politique qui s'impose
bien c'est que toutes les nations se
mettent à une table conférence pour
arrêter ce nouveau génocide planifié et
sans doute ce n'est pas des fusils dont
le peuple cambodgien a besoin mais celle
une aide vraiment une aide en
médicaments en vivre et je supplie les
téléspectateurs d'une panne mesure et
l'inde au cambodge mais cependant vous
savez les difficultés de cette aide et
je demandai je vous en supplie pour le
peuple khmer je vous en supplie le
peuple khmer est en train de mourir
pendant que nous parlons fait pression
sur vos chefs d'état sur ceux qui nous
gouvernent sur l'onu pour envoyer des
casques bleus pour distribuer l'aide
comme le proposait andré bergeron
je pensais la seule proposition solide
et sérieuse dans l'immédiat parce qu'on
vous l'a dit tout à l'heure une grande
partie de l'aide
on va renforcer les armées
tant les armes etc les rouges en
thaïlande que les armées vietnamiennes
au cambodge
et si nous voulons vraiment sauver le
peuple khmer je vous en supplie
intervenez auprès des dirigeants de ce
monde auprès de l'onu auprès de nos
gouvernants pour que des aides
internationales sont soit contrôlée
internationalement par des casques bleus
c'est possible ce n'est pas totalement
irréalisable père pour tous je vous
remercie de cette intervention qui est
la dernière je vous remercie
particulièrement mon seigneur d'avoir
participé à cette émission ce soir à ce
n'est ainsi que vous tous messieurs nous
avons rendez vous mardi prochain pour un
nouveau dossier de l'écran merci votre
attention bonsoir
[Musique]